[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اكد وزير شؤون الاسرى
الفلسطينيين عيسى قراقع ان القياده
الفلسطينيه ستتخذ قرارات مصيريه وان على
اسرائيل ان تتحمل نتائج عمليه المساومه
والابتزاز التي اتبعتها بعدم الافراج عن
الدفعه الرابعه من الاسرى القدامى وكانت
اسرائيل تعهدت باطلاق سراح الاسرى في
اتفاق رعته واشنطن التزمت بموجبه السلطه
الفلسطينيه بعدم اللجوء الى المؤسسات
الدوليه للمطالبه بحقوق الفلسطينيين نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما هو مصير
المفاوضات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
في ظل الخلاف الراهن بينهما حول موضوع
الاسرى م خيارات الفلسطيني ومصير الوساطه
الامريكيه اذا اصر الجانبان على
موقفيهما بنهايه يوم السبت ال9 والع من
مارس كان مؤملا ان تنتهي ماساه 30
فلسطينيا يقبعون في سجون الاحتلال منذ ما
قبل اتفاق اوسلو لولا ان اسرائيل ربطت
وبصوره مفاجئه بين تنفيذ هذا الالتزام و
موضوع لا علاقه له باتفاق تحرير الاسرى
الذي اشرفت عليه الولايات المتحده بموجبه
اطلقت اسرائيل ثلاث دفعات من المعتقلين
اصبحت تل ابيب تشترط الان موافقه
الفلسطينيين على تمديد المفاوضات قبل
اطلاق الدفعه الرابعه من الاسرى اما
واشنطن التي تجاهلت رعايتها هذا الاتفاق
اكتفت بدور ساع البريد ان لم تكن قد قامت
بما هو اكبر حسب ما يتهمها
فلسطينيون تتميز هذه الدفعه من الاسرى
التي اعتقل افرادها الثلا قبل عام
1993 بان 14 بينه من داخل الخط الاخضر
ومحكوم عليهم بالاعدام يمثلون الدفعه
الاخيره ضمن اتفاق يمتنع الفلسطينيون على
اساسه عن طلب عضويه مؤسسات الامم المتحده
الفلسطينيون انخرطوا في هذا المسعى لم
يطلبوا عضويه محافل دوليه لكن تل لم تفرج
عن الاسرى كان الاتفاق باشراف امريكي لكن
دور واشنطن اقتصر على تبليغ الفلسطينيين
بما لا تريده اسرائيل لا يفوت المتابع ان
يلاحظ ان نكث اسرائيل بالاتفاق اعقب رفض
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الاعتراف
بيهوديه اسرائيل وحصولها على الدعم العربي
لهذا الموقف في قمه الكويت وهي القمه التي
عاد منها عباس الى عمان حيث التقى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يوم الاربعاء وابلغه
رفض السلطه فكره تم ديد المفاوضات مع
الاسرائيليين الى نهايه العام كما اقترح
الجانبان الامريكي
والاسرائيلي اثبت الرقض في مسار التفاوض
ان اسرائيل تستمر في تغيير الجغرافيا
والديموغرافيا بالاستيطان والمصادره
والتهويد واذا تم التوصل ال اتفاق ما فان
التجارب اثبتت ان باستطاعه اسرائيل
التراجع عنه وفرض شروط جديده تصبح بدورها
موضوع تفاوض جديد تغطي على المساله
الاصليه يقترح اليسار الاسرائيلي تجميد
الاستيطان اذا لم يطلق سراح الاسرى ويتحدث
مسؤولون فلسطينيون عن خيار اللجوء الى
المحافل الدوليه فهل تفعلها السلطه
الفلسطينيه هذه
المره اذا موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع نمر
حماد المستشار السياسي للرئيس الفلسطيني
من رام الله من رام الله ايضا معنا مصطفى
البرغوثي رئيس المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ومن واشنطن معنا دوج باندا
كبير الباحثين في معهد كيتو والمساعد
الخاص للرئيس ريجن سابقا اهلا بكم جميعا
وابدا معك سيد نمر حماد نريد ان نفهم هذا
الرفض الفلسطيني لتمديد المفاوضات هل هو
فعلا رده فعل على نكوس اسرائيل عن تنفيذ
الاتفاق بشان اطلاق السراح الاسرى ام هو
موقف
استراتيجي مبني ايضا على رؤيه معينه نريد
ان نعرف ما هي
لا هذا موقف مبني على رؤيه وموقف مبني على
اتفاقيات
والتزامات تم التوافق عليها مع الاداره
الامريكيه الاتفاق الذي تم برعايه السيد
جون كيري كان ينص على اطلاق سراح الاسرى
كما يعرف الجميع على اربع دفعات الاسماء
كانت معروفه ابلغنا من الجانب الامريكي
بموافقه اسرائيل على ذلك العدد هو 30 اللي
يفترض ان يتم اطلاق سراحهم الموعد 29 14
منهم من اخواننا في ال
48 بدات اسرائيل تتحدث عن صعوبات بدات
تظهر تسريبات انه لو وافق نتنياهو لسقطت
حكومته انما كل هذا خليني اقول تسريبات
نحن بانتظار ان نعرف رسميا من الراعي
الامريكي ما هو الجواب الاسرائيلي اثنين
ما هو الموقف الامريكي في حال كان الجواب
الاسرائيلي ما يشع الان او الاجواء
الموجوده الان اسرائيل وال الحكه
الاسرائيليه تترع بان اليوم هو ي السبت دا
على اي حال س اجتع لحكه الاسرائيليه سنرى
ماذا سيحصل في هذا الاجتماع نحن من جبنا
لن نربط
اطلاقا موضوع اطلاق سراح الدفعه الثالثه
باي موضوع اخر يعني لا قصه تمديد ست اشهر
ولا تمديد اربعه اشهر ولا غير ذلك نحن من
البدايه ابلغنا الاداره الامريكيه وتعرف
ذلك اسرائيل ان اطلاق سراح الاسرى مرتبط
بعدم ذهاب الفلسطينيين بارادتهم بقرار
منهم الى المنظمات الدوليه لكن اذا لم
يحترم هذا الاتفاق
فان القياده الفلسطينيه نعم ستذهب الى
المنظمات الدوليه بدءا من محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه وغيرها هذا هو الموقف الفلسطيني
بمنتهى الوضوح يعني ليست عمليه تغيير في
الموقف هذا الموقف معروف جيدا ليس فقط
معروف للشعب الفلسطيني ومعروف لكم معروف
ايضا للاداره الامريكيه ومعروف جيدا ايضا
للحكومه الاسرائيليه اذا المساران منفصلان
ولكن رغم ذلك سمعنا عيسى قراقع اليوم يقول
ان يعني لن يتم الموافقه على تمديد
المفاوضات ما لم يتم اطلاق سراح الاسرى ال
اذا بمعنى اخر تم الربط من
جانبكم انا حتى الان يعني كما قلت
لك لا نستطيع الان يعني في هذه اللحظه ان
نقول ان هناك رفض لم نبلغ بان هناك رفض
هناك اجواء
خلقتها الحكومه الاسرائيليه توحي بانها لا
تريد ان تنفذ لكن من الذي يجب ان يعطي
الجواب الذي رعى هذه المبادره وهو الجانب
الامريكي يعني احنا ان استبق الامور وقالت
الولايات المتحده بكره ان الفلسطينيين
تسرعوا
وا اوقفوا جهودنا عرقلوا
مساعينا القياده الفلسطينيه ايضا تتصرف
بمسؤوليه بعقلانيه اي
بثبات لا نريد ان نعطي ذريعه لا نريد ان
نوحد الموقف الاسرائيلي الامريكي رغم كل
ما بينهما من علاقات علينا ان ننتظر ماذا
سيحصل غدا في اجتماع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ماذا ستقول الحكومه الاسرائيليه للاداره
الامريكيه ليست فقط لنا يعني ربما با
اجتماع يوم غد نسمع كلام من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انه يريدوا ان يربطوا اطلاق
سراح بموضوع اخر لن نقبل هذا يعني ما
سمعناه من زياد ابو عين وما سمعناه من
جبريل ابو رجوب هو موقف واضح موقف
اسرائيلي واضح ابلغ عن طريق مارتن اندك
وهذا ما اريد ان يعني اسال السيد بداو
عنه بعد يوم واحد فقط من اجتماع كيري بابي
مازن في
عمان ياتي نقل الرساله نقل الشرط
الاسرائيلي بهذه الصوره من قبل مارتن اندك
والربط الذي تحدث عنه نمر حماد بين ملفين
يفترض ان واشنطن اكثر من يعرف ان لا علاقه
لهم
ببعض كيف يفهم هذا يفهم ان هناك تنسيق او
على الاقل مباركه امريكيه لهذا الموقف
الاسرائيلي لا
اعتقد لا اعتقد ان هذه مباركه امريكيه بل
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تريد ابقاء
استمرار المفاوضات وهي تواجه الان طلبا من
اسرائيل لم تكن تتوقعه وبالتالي فان جون
كيري قد استثمر وقتا طويلا في هذه
المفاوضات التي هي مستمره منذ اشهر وهو
ملتزم بها تماما وهو يقوم كل ما في وسعه
لاستمرارها وذلك لا اعتقد بانه سعيد وراضي
من الموقف الاسرائيلي ولكني لا اعتقد ان
بامكانه ان يغيره وبالتالي فهو يريد ان
يبدي الجانب الفلسطيني مرونه اكبر وهو
يعلم ان ذلك قد يؤثر على الرئيس عباس
ويسبب سبب له بعض المشاكل وكن يعني لا
يفهم بصراحه هذا الموقف يعني يفترض ان
الراعي الوسيط الذي اشرف على اتفاقيه
معينه هو الان بدل ان يقنع الطرف
الاسرائيلي يحاول ان يقنع الطرف الفلسطيني
بالتنازل من جديد
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذا
هو تاريخ المشاركه او التورط الامريكي في
هذه المحادثات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
فالولايات المتحده قريبه جدا من اسرائيل
وستحظى دائما مثل هذه العلاقه الوثيقه
معها وبالتالي فانها دائما يمكن ان تحصل
تصلها مثل هذه الطلبات من اسرائيل وان
الاداره الامريكيه مث الحاليه تود استمرار
المفاوضات وهي استثمرت كميه كبيره من
الجهد فيها واذا ما وجدت ان اسرائيل
ستعارض فانها تضطر الى الضغط على
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي يعتقد ان هذا جزء من
نمط شائع وهو ما يقوم به الوزير كيري لكن
ليس لديه اي بديل عن ذلك لانه يستطيع
اقناع الاسرائيليين بتغيير موقفهم
طيب مصطفى البرغوثي يعني واضح يعني
استمعنا الى وجهات نظر ولكن ما سمعناه من
جبريل الرجوب ايضا لافت عندما يعتبر ان
الموقف الاسرائيلي صفع اسرائيليه قويه
للاداره الاسرائيليه هل هذا يعني وقت
تباكي على الكرامه الامريكيه على الكرامه
الامريكيه طبعا انا قلت اداره الاداره
الامريكيه هل هذا فعلا وقت التباكي على
هذا هذا وقته
انا اعتقد انه انا لست بحاجه لان اتحدث
بلغه دبلوماسيه لذلك ساكون صريحا
تماما الذي يجري اليوم هو تاكيد لما حذرنا
منه من قبل وهو انه كان اصلا من الخطا
البدء بكل ه المفاوضات دون وقف شامل ومطلق
للاستيطان
ودون مرجعيات واضحه ما حذرنا منه يحدث
الان اسرائيل تستغل قضيه الاسرى وهم اسرى
كان اصلا يجب ان يفرج عنهم قبل 20 عام
وكان خطا توقيع اتفاق اسلو دون الافراج
عنهم والان تستغل اسرائيل الامهم من اجل
ان تفرض شروط سياسيه وهي تقول انها لن
تفرج عن هذه الدفعه الا اذا وافق
الفلسطينيون على تمديد المفاوضات السؤال
الرئيسي لماذا اسرائيل معنيه بتمديد
المفاوضات لانها تستعمل هذه المفاوضات
غطاء للتوسع الاستيطاني وغطاء للجرائم ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني على مدار الثمانيه اشهر
الماضيه زادت اسرائيل وتيره التوسع
الاستيطاني بنسبه 13344 بال
اكثر مما كانت عليه قبل المفاوضات وخلال
نفس الفتره قامت اسرائيل باغتيال 54 شهيد
فلسطيني بدم بارد وحاولت ان تحرج الجميع
بما في ذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه باقتحامها
لكافه المناطق الفلسطينيه نحن نتحدث ليس
عن عمليه متكافئه ستؤدي الى نتائج نحن
نتحدث عن محاولات اسرائيل للاملاء والدليل
على ذلك المقترحات التي يقدمها كيري والتي
لم تعد خافيه او سرا على احد مقترحات كيري
منحازه بالكامل لاسرائيل
مقترحات كيري تعني تصفيه حقنا في القدس
عاصمه للفلسطينيين تعني تصفيه حق اللاجئين
في العوده الى ديارهم تعني تصفيه حقنا في
ان تقوم لنا دوله مستقله واستبدالها ببانو
سانات وكونا محاصره بالوجود الاسرائيلي
وبسيطه الاسرائيليه مقترحات كيري ببساطه
تعني ان لا يكون لنا دوله حقيقيه وان نبقى
فعليا تحت في ظل نظام احتلال وابار تيد
وفصل عنصري
وبموافقته الاسر ودعيني اذكر انه في 76
اسير تم الافراج عنهم ونحن نريد لكل اسير
ان يرى الحريه طبعا ولكن خلال نفس الفتره
قامت اسرائيل باعتقال اكثر من 700 اسير
اخر يعني ع اضعاف من افرج عنهم هي دائره
لا يمكن ان تستمر وبالتالي الذي يجري هو
ابتزاز اسرائيلي يجب رفضه ونحن نتوقع ان
يتم تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه وما وعدنا
به ان تقرر قياده منظمه التحرير ردا على
ما قامت به اسرائيل التوجه الفوري لكافه م
سسات الامم المتحده بما في ذلك الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه في نهايه المطاف بما في
ذلك توقيع كل المعاهدات الدوليه لانه
بصراحه المراهنه على مفاوضات مع حكومه
التطرف العنصري الاسوا في تاريخ اسرائيل
هي براي مراهنه فاشله وخاسر ولن تؤدي الى
نتائج اذا ربما يفتح هذا الباب على موضوع
الخيارات الفلسطينيه في المرحله المقبله
وهذا ما سنناقشه بعد فاصل قصير ارجو ان
تبقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها مصير المفاوضات الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه في ضوء رفض تل ابيب اطلاق سراح
الدفعه الرابعه من الاسرى والان بصدد
مناقشه الخيارات الم المطروحه الان
بالنسبه للجانبين ابدا معك سيد بداو يعني
بدءا ب الصفعه الاولى التي تلقاها اوباما
في موضوع الاستيطان مرورا بمحاولات كثيره
لاستئناف المفاوضات وانتهاء بالموقف
الاخير الذي قبلت فيه واشنطن على ما يبدو
بدور ساعي البريد وان تقبل بنكوس اسرائيل
عن قرار هي بنفسه
رعته اذا الا يعزز هذا فكره ان الولايات
المتحده لم
ليست الوسيط النزيه المناسب لهذه
المفاوضات اعتقد انها مشكله بالنسبه لهذه
الاداره
فالاداريس بين الطرفين ولكنني اعتقد ان كل
من ينظر الى هذا الموضوع لابد ان يدرك
ويعترف انه خلال السنوات ال 40 وال
الماضيه كانت الولايات المتحده حليفا قويا
لاسرائيل وبالتالي فكل من يرى دور
الولايات المتحده كوسيط يرى بانها تتاثر
بهذه العلاقه الطويله وهذه مجرد فصل جديد
في هذه العلاقه وان الرئيس اوباما ضغط على
اسرائيل كثيرا لكي لا تستمر في بناء
المستوطنات ولكن اسرائيل استمرت في ذلك
رغم ذلك ورغم ذلك بقي الرئيس اوباما
ملتزما بتشجيع هذه المفاوضات وق وبتالي
قرر قبول الامر والاستمرار وهذا ما يقوم
به الوزير كيري ولا اعتقد الوزير كيري
سعيد بهذه النتيجه ولكنه يامل ان تستمر
المفاوضات وان يحقق تقدما فيها ولكنني
افهم لماذا ان الجانب الفلسطيني يشعر
باحباط كبير لنسال نر حماد هل فعلا ما
زلتم تنظرون للولايات متحده كنزيه وسيط
مناسب للمفاوضات بعد هذا
الموقف يعني انا انا بعتقد ما قاله السيد
دوك باندا و كلام صحيح وكلام واضح هناك
علاقه خاصه جدا ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
واسرائيل
اسرائيل تعامل في امريكا وكانها احدى
الولايات الامريكيه ولذلك كثيرا مرارى
تناقد كبير ما بين موقف الاداره الامريكيه
و
وزن ودور الكونجرس الامريكي السيد جون
كيري بذل جهودا كبيره ويجب ان نعترف بذلك
السيد جون كيري قبل زيارته للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه كان موجود في روما اثناء
وجوده صرحت الناطقه الرسميه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وقالت ان الدفعه
الرابعه من الاسر على اي حال عدد الاسرى
104 وليس 140 كما ورد يعني بعتقد خطا على
الشاشه اعلنت انه سيتم الالتزام
و احن مع الاداره الامريكيه خليني اوضح
يعني كيف يجري النقاش احن بنقول انتم
يفترض انكم وسطاء والوسيط يجب ان يكون
نزيه والسيد جون كيري قال اذا وصلنا الى
طريق مسدود سنعلن من هو المسؤول عن الفشل
هذا ما قيل الان عندما نناقش الجانب
الامريكي في بعض الاقتراحات التي تقدم لنا
نقول هل هذا موقفكم بقولوا لا هذا ما
تطالب به اسرائيل جوابنا انه طيب هذا ما
تطالب به اسرائيل لكن انتم كوسيط ما هو
موقفكم الاداره هذه تقول انها لا تريد ان
تعزل نفسها كما حصل مع ادارات سابقه مجلس
حقوق الانسان يوم اول امس 46 دوله صوتت
الى جانب قرارات خاصه بدعم فلسطين تدين
اسرائيل الولايات المتحده وقفت
وحيده السؤال هل هذه المره ايضا يمكن
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تقول انه
الجانبين لم يتجاوبوا وبالتالي تحاول انه
تتهرب من التزامها تتهرب مما تعهدت به
بالقول الجانبين هذه الصيغه التي اصبحت
غير مقبوله هل ستمارس الولايات المتحده
ضغوط على اوروبا من اجل عدم الذهاب بعيدا
في العقوبات التي تفرض على اسرائيل نحن
نتمنى ان هذه الاداره لا تتصرف كما حصل في
ادارات سابقه وهي باستمرار وفي اللحظات
الحاسمه لاعتبارات داخليه امريكيه
لاعتبارات اخرى عديده
تتخذ جانب اسرائيل وفي النهايه الولايات
المتحده تتاثر اذا كان فعلا هناك موقف
نهائي من جانبكم
بوقف المفاوضات هذا التهديد بوقف
المفاوضات هل هو نهائي
انا باكد لك التالي يعني من شان يعني ما
التقدير لما قاله اخي وصديقي الدكتور
مصطفى احيانا المهم ان تتخذي القرار
الصحيح في الوقت الصحيح وان تاخذي بعين
الاعتبار موازين القوى مش دائما كل شيء صح
اذا ما كان التوقيت غير صحيح نحن وصلنا
الى مرحله فعلا بعد كل هذه الجهود وخليني
اقول التي بذلتها ايضا الولايات المتحده
مش امام كل الوضع الاقليمي المحيط بنا
وصلنا الى نتيجه تقول انه تسعه اشهر حتى
الان يعني ثمانه اشهر حتى لا اقول عن
مبادرات عديده سابقه مفاوضات تقريبيه
مرينا بكل الانواع الاستيطان استمر تهويد
القدس استمر وصلنا الى مرحله الان عنوانها
قضيتين القضيه الاولى واضح ان الولايات
المتحده لوحدها لا تستطيع ان تكون وسيطا
نزيها في حل هذا الصراع هل ستقبل بتوسيع
الدائره بحيث يكون دور حقيقي للجنه
الرباعيه لدينا شقوق لانه للاسف ايضا
تجربتنا غير مبشره اذا سنذهب الى الامم
المتحده
ومنظماتها من اجل ان نعيد قضيه فلسطين الى
المجتمع الدولي وسيكون موضوع المفاوضات
بالنس لنا مووع خلفنا اذا لم يكن
هناك جدول زمني للانسحاب
صيغه مقبه من العالم مع ضمانات بانها
فر اذا لم يتحقق هذا لم ي للشعب الفلسطيني
ما يخسره احنا قرارنا سنبقى على ارضنا
وهذا شي مهم سنوفر ما اقصى ما نستطيع من
عوامل الصمود للشعب الفلسطيني على ارضه
الاستيطان اذا بقي الشعب الفلسطيني على
ارضه بالاخر لا مستقبل له احنا 138 ال
فلسطيني بقيوا داخل اسرائيل
الي هذه النه يعني فعلا هل الوقت مناسب هل
وصلت الامور الى حد فعلا هناك جديه تامه
من جانب المفاوض الفلسطيني باخذ الامور
الى مرحله
اخرى انا امل ذلك لانه القضيه لا تدور حول
ثمانه اشهر احنا هناك اجتهاد فلسطيني كان
قائم من قبل قياده منظمه تحرير على مدار
21 سنه من يوم ما وقع اتفاق اوسلو يكفي
يعني 21 سنه تكفي لكي نصل الى القناعه
الحقيقيه والتي يعرفها اي طالب في اي كليه
علوم سياسيه انه اذا لم يكن ميزان القوى
لصالحنا فان المفاوضات لا يمكن ان تاتي
بشيء المراهنه على الاداره الامريكيه ايضا
مراهنه في غير مكانها الابسط دليل على ذلك
انه اوباما نفسه قبل اكثر من ست سنوات وقف
في القاهره ودعا الى وقف الاستيطان ثم
اضطر ان يبلع ما دعا اليه اذا هذا يعني ان
الولايات المتحده غير قادره على ان تكون
لا نعم لا قادره ان تكون وسيط نزيه ولا
قادره ان تكون وسيط فعلي فعلي السؤال
الرئيسي الذي يواجه الشعب الفلسطيني ونحن
كقوى فلسطينيه يجب ان نجيب شعبنا هل هناك
بديل للطريق الفاشل اللي اسمه المفاوضات
نعم هناك بديل وبديل فعال بديل على الارض
اليوم الشباب يعتصم في باب الكرامه في
منطقه الجفتلك في الاغوار مثل ما فعلنا في
عين حجله ومثل ما فعلنا في باب الشمس ومثل
ما تفعل القرى الفلسطينيه في المقاومه
الشعبيه البديل هو الجمع ما بين المقاومه
الشعبيه وحركه المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على
اسرائيل التي اصبحت تؤتي ثمار رائعه وما
جرى مع الاتحاد الاوروبي هو مج مجرد احد
مظاهر هذا الضغط الشعبي الرائع الذي يجري
بحركه المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات وايضا
البديل هو الاسراع في تحقيق الوحده
الوطنيه وانهاء الانقسام القائم حاليا حتى
نوحد كل طاقاتنا ونجاه العالم باستراتيجيه
وطنيه موحده ورابعا نحن بحاجه الى سياسات
فعلا تدعم صمود الناس وبقائهم وثباتهم على
الارض لانه نحن نواجه عدو معقد وخطير وقوي
والمساله تشمل اشياء عديده تشمل احتلال هو
الاطول في التاريخ الحديث نظام فصل عنصري
اسوا مما كان في جنوب افريقيا ونظام تطهير
عرقي وبالتالي هدفنا الوطني يجب ان يكون
ثباتنا وبقائنا على ارض وطنا ولكن هذا
الثبات يجب ان يكون ثبات مقاوم وبالتالي
الحل هو في مقاومه الاسرائيليين والعمل
على تغيير ميزان القوى واقناع شعبنا بان
هناك امل المراهنه على مفاوضات عقيمه لن
تاتي بنتيجه انا اعتقد كل الناس مقتنعه
بهذا الحكي ولكن اذا كانت المساله مساله
توقيت فالان هو التوقيت لكي ننهي هذا
الفصل لكي نقول للعالم بدكم اطار
المفاوضات فليكن اطار دولي متوازن لا
تنفرد فيه الولايات المتحده وان يكون على
اساس ميزان لنرى اذا كانت الاداره
الفلسطينيه ستقتنع بان هذا هو الوقت
المناسب سيبقى تبقى هذه النقطه معلقه شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام
الله رئيس المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
وشكرا جزيلا لنمر حماد المستشار السياسي
للرئيس الفلسطيني وشكرا لدوك بداو كبير
الباحثين في معهد كيتو والمساعد الخاص
للرئيس ريجن سابقا وشكرا لكم انتم
مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من
بر نامج ما وراء الخبر فيما
[موسيقى]
لا